ハジメ：ちょもうマジもう無理なんすよぉ
ギャラリー：どしたん？
ギャラリー：え？
ギャラリー：どしたん？（2回目）
ギャラリー：どしたん？（3回目）
ハジメ：もうなんかしらんけどすごい今日怒こりたくてぇ...
ギャラリー：なにがー？
ギャラリー：なに？
ハジメ：もうおこだよ
ギャラリー：なにおこって？
ギャラリー：ちょだから言ってみてよなに？なににたいしておこってんの？
ハジメ：おれ今日おこだわ
ギャラリー：だからなに？なに？何に対して怒ってんの？
ハジメ腕：ﾍﾟﾁッ(もやしのような腕から繰り出された小さな音)
ハジメ：もうおこだよ！
ギャラリー：だからなに？ナンダヨー何にたいして？
マウス：カチッ(マウス)
マウス：カチッ（2回目）(マウス)
マウス：カチッ（3回目）(マウス)
タンタンタッｗｗｗｗｗｗｗタンッタンッタｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ×８
マウス：カチッ（4回目）
ギャラリー：ふふっwなにこいつww
ギャラリー：なに？ww　え？w
ギャラリー：ッwwえ？wwどういうこと？ｗｗ
ギャラリー：うん「お」
ギャラリー：「こ」ぉぉぉ
ハァァァァァァァァｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
ギャラリー：こいつちょっとガリガリwwガリガリじゃないとwww
ギャラリー：ちょっとガリガリじゃない？
ギャラリー：もうなんか、フライパンの上でおどってるもやしみたいｗ
ギャラリー：やばっｗ
ギャラリー：な、なに？ｗ
ギャラリー：おおっ
ギャラリー：うぉ！
ギャラリー：なんか阿修羅みたい。スゴーイ(棒)
ギャラリー：お前ケータイ見ながら見てるwwwwww
パッｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗパッｗｗｗパァラｗｗｗｗｗｗ×４
ギャラリー：これどうしろっていうの？これ俺らに見せて
ギャラリー：でもこれなんか女の人のおっぱいみたいｗｗやめろよｗｗ変な感じに見えちゃう
ギャラリー：やばいトミックににてるｗｗ
ギャラリー（トミック）：なんでだよｗｗ
ギャラリー：なんかターミネーター2の
ギャラリー：T1000型みたいｗ
ギャラリー：うわめっちゃにてるｗ
ギャラリー：だれだよ？ｗ
ギャラリー：（トミックを指しながら）おまえｗｗ
ギャラリー：うるせぇよｗ
ギャラリー：あ、萌えた萌えたｗ
ギャラリー：なんか来るんじゃない？始まるんじゃない？
ギャラリー：おおっ？
ギャラリー：おおっ？（2回目）
ギャラリー：始まるよ絶対なんかはじまるよ
ギャラリー：これ恭ちゃん(恭一郎)のパクリじゃない？
ギャラリー：言おうか迷ったけどパクリだよね？
ギャラリー：ちょっとドラクエはいってるしね
ギャラリー：体型まったくパクれてないけどねｗｗ(つまりもやし)
ギャラリー：すげぇｗ
ギャラリー：気持ちわるー(素の言葉)
ギャラリー：これ...雪ふるんだよねこの後
ギャラリー：パクリなら雪降るよね
ギャラリー：ほらふったふった
ギャラリー：うわほんとだすげぇｗ
ギャラリー：よくわかったね？　いやパクリだもん
ギャラリー：ぱちぱちぱち
マホト：ちょまってこれ何におこったの？
トミック：うん
マホト：これなんにおこったの？